Let us begin by asking ourselves,
why do we need use formal logic to design an AI agent? The way the formal logic
in an AI agent would work is that there will be two parts to the AI agent.
The first part of the agent will consist of a knowledge base.
The knowledge will contain the agents knowledge all over the world.
That knowledge will be represented in sentences in the language of logic.
The second part will consist of an inference engine. The inference engine will
apply rules of inference to the knowledge that the agent has. So remember again,
two parts, the knowledge base and then rules of inference. Now there are certain
situations in which we want the AI agent to be able to show, to be able to prove
that the answers, that it derives to any problem in fact are provably correct.
If we want to show this to itself, or to other users. In other situations,
we may want the AI agent to generate only provably correct solutions. How can we
guarantee that? Well we need two things. First, we need a complete and
correct knowledge base. And second, we need rules of inference that will give
guarantees of correctness of the answer. The inference then has two parts to it.
The first part is called soundness. The property of soundness means that
rules of inference will derive only those conclusions that are,
in fact, valid. The second property is completeness. The property of
completeness means that the [UNKNOWN] will derive all of the valid conclusions.
These are two very important properties to have. If an AI agent can use
logical rules, logical rules of inference on its knowledge base and
provide guaranteed soundness and completeness, then it's a very useful thing for
an AI agent to have. For this reason, logic has been an important part of
AI since the inception of the field. In fact it continues to be
an important part of research and modeling AI. In this course however we'll
discuss logic only to a very limited degree. There are two reasons for
this. First, our priorities in this course are a little different.
Instead of talking about knowledge in the form of logical sentences, we are much
more interested in conceptual knowledge and experiential knowledge and
heuristic knowledge. Second, recall that we said that a logic
based agent has two parts to it, the knowledge base and the rules of inferences.
Even if the rules of inferences are, in fact, guaranteed to be sound and
complete, there is a problem about how do we construct a correct and
complete knowledge base? If the knowledge base of an AI agent is not correct and
complete, then it may not gave you useful answers,
even if the roots of inference are sound and complete. Thus, in this course,
we'll use logic only to the degree to which it is useful for
specifying other methods. Methods that use conceptual knowledge or
experiential knowledge or heuristic knowledge.